well badly needed humanitarian aid from
the US and other countries is becoming a
pawn in the deepening crisis in
Venezuela the government of Nicolas
Maduro used a fuel tanker and cargo
trailers yesterday to block a bridge
that connects Venezuela to Colombia
the standoff came as the u.s. and
supplies to the border area Manuel
Bojorquez is in Caracas Venezuela with
the struggle to deliver food and
medicine it could be the biggest test
yet for the two men claiming to lead
this country opposition leader Hwang
bwado stands to gain ground if he can
get food and medicine to where it's
desperately needed but those loyal to
Maduro say they cannot be bought Maduro
is your president this West Caracas
barrio is as Pro Maduro as it gets it's
controlled by a so called colectivo
groups of civilians who act as police
and enforce the rule of government
you're not worried about who's gonna be
president here because in your view so
let Maduro it's just my Jefferson
Gonzalez is part of the colectivo Ocasio
you take care of people's health and
education here the colectivo controls
access the airwaves so this is a direct
nofilter message to the people here and
they even have their own currency but
there's few places to spend it so people
have been in line since 5 a.m. and where
you can spend it there are long lines
for food Gonzalez says the working-class
neighbourhoods named benign or hive is
also a warning if your worker bees but
it's also will sting you with you attack
in fact the colectivos can be more like
armed gangs they're believed to have
been part of an attack on opposition
lawmakers in 2017 and they vowed to
stand by Maduro until the end but there
are signs support for him among the
military apparatus is cracking reform
all my salary isn't even enough to buy
food this Venezuelan soldier agreed to
speak with CBS News is Elizabeth Palmer
on the condition we hide his face and
disguise his voice we are suffering just
like the people are while Maputo appears
almost daily on state TV to show the
military support the soldiers said many
in uniform are wait
for one thing in the National Guard all
we need is a high-ranking general to
rebel to lead the way White House
National Security Advisor John Bolton
said the US would consider lifting
sanctions for any senior military
officer who switched sides to the
opposition leader Huang Cueto but so far
the vast majority appear to be standing
firm for CBS this morning I'm Manuel
Bojorquez in Caracas Venezuela